bringt uns der neunte planet den tod
eine beängstigende theorie über das
massensterben auf der erde trifft ein
cometen schauer unserem planeten
erst jüngst wurden indizien für den
neunten planeten entdeckt dieser im
kuiper gürtel unseres sonnensystems
vermutete planet könnte in periodischen
abständen zerstörung und tod auf die
erde bringen diese these vertritt denn
erik meijer ist professor für physik an
der university of louisiana lafayette
und zugleich der vertreter seiner
eigenen ursachen theorie bezüglich des
periodischen massensterbens mit mayer
zufolge würde der unbekannte planet bei
seiner leicht schrägen runde um die
sonne in regelmäßigen abständen cometen
schauer auf die erde schießen diese
gesteins schauer hätten der erde in der
vergangenheit nicht nur schäden in form
von einschlägen zugefügt sondern auch in
form von drastischen klimaveränderung
wie jedes tier und auch nicht jede
pflanze aber dann mit solchen
veränderungen umgehen können
bei seiner leicht schrägen runde das
kommt euch noch bekannt vor wickmayer
hält den neunten planeten von dem wir
schon einmal berichtet haben für seinen
unbekannten planeten als er seine
theorie bereits 1985 verfasste gab es
über diesen planeten allerdings
überhaupt keine erkenntnisse
jetzt gibt es diese womit wittmeier
wieder auf seine theorie aufmerksam
macht aber worum handelt es sich bei
diesen periodischen massensterben ein
großes periodisches massensterben trete
wissenschaftlern zufolge alle 62
millionen jahre auf und zerstörte bisher
immer eine menge lebewesen kleinere
ereignisse derart würden sogar alle 27
millionen jahre eintreten
im jahr 2005 berichteten die forscher
robert rothe und richard mueller von der
university of california in berkeley im
fachmagazin nature über dieses
periodische phänomen und dass das
nächste massensterben eigentlich schon
lange überfällig wäre ihnen zufolge
seien im jahr 2005 schon 65 millionen
jahre seit dem letzten mal vergangen
damals hätten die dinosaurier dran
glauben müssen die ursache für dieses
phänomen konnte sich damals noch keiner
erklären die theorie von wickmayer
könnte es aber erklären und die tatsache
dass erst kürzlich neue erkenntnisse zu
dem neunten planeten gewonnen werden
konnten bekräftigt diese natürlich auch
noch forscher vom california institute
of technology caltech
im januar rein hypothetisch diesen einen
neuen planeten in unserem sonnensystem
entdeckt der trägt den namen planet 9
die forscher gehen davon aus dass
planeten existieren muss da sich einige
objekte im kuiper gürtel auffällig
verhalten was ihr bewegungsverhalten im
raum angeht
es muss eine kraft geben die sie
beeinflusst das konnten sie anhand einer
computersimulation feststellen
die größe des planeten soll circa zehn
erdmassen entsprechen aufgrund seiner
entfernung zur sonne muss es sich um
einen eisplaneten handeln für eine
umrundung der sonne müsste er zwischen
10 und 20 tausend jahren benötigen
kleine gedankenstütze wir brauchen mit
der esa für ein jahr objekte dort am
rande des sonnensystems überhaupt zu
entdecken ist übrigens sehr schwierig im
jahr 2003 wurde sedna mit hilfe von
weltraumteleskopen entdeckt das objekt
kann man vermutlich alsfeld planeten
kategorien 2005 gelang es unter der
mitarbeit von michael braun den
zwergplaneten make make zu entdecken hat
einen ungefähr durchmesser von 1500
kilometern und braun geht davon aus dass
es noch mehr gibt zitat ich vermute dass
es mindestens ein wenig sogar mehrere
bislang unbekannte objekte dort draußen
gibt das sagte er schon letztes jahr in
einem interview mit dem spiegel 70.000
objekte sollen sich im kuiper gürtel
befinden und das sind nur die objekte
mit einem durchmesser von mehr als 100
kilometern übrigens vermuten brown und
seine kollegen dass sich planet 9
vor rund viereinhalb milliarden jahren
viel näher an der sonne befunden haben
könnte durch die gravitation der anderen
planeten soll er dann immer weiter an
den rand des sonnensystems gedrückt
worden sein und das würde vielleicht
auch erklären warum das massensterben
noch auf sich warten lässt je weiter der
planet weg ist desto länger braucht er
um wieder in die position zu kommen in
der kometen schauer auf die erde
schießen werden wenn euch das video
gefallen hat las einen daumen nach oben
da und abonniert klicks um kostenlos
einfach den abo button anklicken was
glaubt ihr
sind solche naturkatastrophen
unausweichlich oder können wir uns
irgendwie dagegen wären schreibt sie in
den kommentaren rast bleibt noch zu
sagen bis dann bleibt dran